good afternoon everyone and welcome to
our latest live interview from the
european parliament we are live on
facebook and youtube my name is maria
and i'm here to discuss how the ears
plan to
to make its food production more
independent together with the chair of
parliament's committee of agriculture mr
robert norbert lynch welcome mr linz
so good afternoon russian's invasion of
ukraine has seen a drop in grain and
fertilizer exports from these two
countries and has raised concerns over
food security right so there is a lot to
discuss in the next half an hour or so
but before we get on the way with the
interview i would like to to invite our
followers to our followers to send us
their questions and comments and i'll
put as many as possible to my guests
so mr lienz ukraine is known as the
bread basket for europe since it's a
huge sport of cereals and together with
russia they provide over a third of the
world's
wheats and berlin 17 of corn and over 50
percent of sunflower oil and seeds so
will the invasion of ukraine spark a
global food insecurity crisis
yes i i think so
clearly
yes i just
had
a briefing with the foul with the world
food organization and
i've really concerned about food
security
um in the world but especially when it
comes to northern africa the middle and
the far east because they are
yeah more or less a hundred percent um
dependent on exports from ukraine
and
russia or i would say they were
dependent for a hundred percent on on on
exports from from these countries
however the eu is one of the top
providers of humanitarian food and
nutrition assistance globally so what is
the eu doing to help these non-eu
countries uh to tackle the crisis
yeah so
i would say we as the european union we
are not um
able to replace all the export
coming from ukraine in russia so that is
there we have
not that much land and and not much
not that much production but we can
replace um a part of that and that's our
in my view that's our aim and we have
to do
all um as much as we can
to guarantee
a higher production
than in the years before that this means
that we
have to use all the available arable
land
in the european in the european union
and does the the war pose an immediate
grave threat to food supplies of
european citizens
i would say for the
year
2022
i would say there we in the european
union
we will not have uh
food shortages so that food is not
available anymore i think we will
have the challenge that some products
are no more available we see that with
sunflower oils and this is now replaced
by olive oil and we will see
some
special products which um yeah where we
saw that the raw materials
were exported
from ukraine or russia
but this does not mean that in my view
that we will face food insecurity in the
european union but people have to
replace some products they use and and
they have to use different products
and so do you think that you will reduce
it its dependence on imports for example
and if so how would they do it
yeah so for the european union so we are
dispen dependent as well from from
imports
from the ukraine and or more from the
ukraine than from russia
but
this is more when it comes to feed
ingredients so where we
have to feed
our
animals
and
there we
have now the chance to as well not only
produce
more wheat for certain countries um
and especially for northern africa and
the far in the middle east
but as well we have to increase our feed
and production and this
means that we have to increase our
our arable lands for protein crops
for syria and leguminosis and and and so
on and this is
one part of the crisis
measures the the commission proposed to
the member states
so war on the ground in ukraine is
preventing the internal movements of
goods and particularly food but as you
also said feed and other ugly culture
products so is the european union
helping ukraine to ensure food security
there
yes
first when we saw
the crisis measures from the european
commission that there is a new emergency
emergency support program
with an amount of 330 million
euros and
the commission is very active
to
get
to get
the products
to the ukrainian to the ukrainian people
but that's not um that's not that easy
because normally we should uh have the
possibility to establish a so-called
green corridor to guarantee an export
from ukraine but
imports as well from the european union
and this is still a challenge to to
establish or
to introduce this
green
this green corridor
and can we expect rising consumer food
prices due to the ukraine crisis
and what can the eu do to tackle this
yeah so we see that all the prices for
food are raising since months so this
was a
trend before the ukraine war but it's
clear that now
we the the the
raise of prices
remain still or will be higher
than before
we see that with meat we see that with
corn
and this has different
backgrounds for example the price for
the ingredients for
farmers are higher than before
especially the price for fertilizers
they we can
say more or less they are four times
higher than one year before so there you
see the production costs for the farmer
are much more higher than one year ago
yeah and in this sense
how is the european union helping these
farmers
yeah first
we use
the first time in this cup period the
crisis reserve and i appreciate that the
crisis
reserve has an about amount of 500
million euros and this can be tripled by
the member states for example my own
member state germany
offers now an amount of 180 million
euros
to the farmers that they can deal
with the higher production costs
and
and so on so this is one
one instrument and the commission opened
the possibility for member states to
support to support farmers when it comes
to fertilizers not that they can benefit
from a
state aid
from the member states to buy
fertilizers for example my neighbor
country poland immediately use
used that measures
and the third one and in my view the
most
important one is
that we opened the so-called ecological
focus areas
to
for the production for brought it in
crops but as well
for weeds and i appreciate that
the commission opened that area
as well
for the farmers to use pesticides to
guarantee a good outcome to guarantee a
good harvest
for this year so these areas mean that
uh yeah that farmers now can use
fertilizers that they couldn't use uh
before right yeah so they have now the
possibility to use especially pesticides
which was not allowed since
six years and
so
so
they were obliged to use that area
extensively so this was not set aside
land but it was
the obligation to use that in in an
extensive way yeah and now they can
re-intensify
intensify
the the land and will this be
provisional or temporary measures yes
it's clear a temporary measure as you
may know that we are in the last year of
the cup from 2013
14 to 2022
and this means we are now in the last
year of the current common agriculture
policy and
i fully support this that this measure
is
for the time being
allowed temporarily so this means only
for 2022
but we have in my view we have to open
the discussion um
when it comes to 2023
um because i see food
shortages
not only in 2022 so this will remain
in 2023 so we have
to guarantee that farmers are able to
pre produce as much that they
they can in 2023 as well
um
in relation to what you have just
explained we have a live question from
one of our viewers she said albena and
she's asking what is the understanding
of your committee regarding seeking a
balance
between industrialization of agriculture
and
more climate friendly and more
consumer-friendly production of food
yeah so
there i would ask back what does she
mean with industrialization so which
farm or how
large should the farm be
that the farm is an
industrialized one so no one
answered me at this question till till
now
so
this would be
this would be of interest
for me to know what's industrialized and
and what is not so when you look into my
country
so we have 27
member states with totally different
agriculture structures
for example in my country we have large
farms in the eastern part of germany we
have um
a large farm or larger farms as well in
the northern part and where i'm from i'm
from the south of germany now we have
the the smallest farm in in the
in in germany with the average the size
of 36 hectare or i give you another
example in portugal 90 of the farms they
have
an average or they they have an uh a
number of hectares which are less than
10 hectares yeah so and then another a
totally different situation in some
especially in the eastern part of the
european union where you have in some
areas
really large
scale farms and in other you have the
smallest farms in the european union
often less than one or
two hectares so we have to find um
always we have to find a balance between
[Music]
the question how we can guarantee food
security on the one hand and how can we
guarantee that
agriculture and
[Music]
agriculture and the forest sector
contributes to our climate
to our climate and biodiversity goals
this is always a question
in my committee yeah
it is true that after russia invaded
ukraine there have been many discussions
on about suspending some environmental
protection
in the name of maximizing production so
would you say is
food security could be compatible with
organic farming
yes so in my view
so
as i was shadow rapper for the organic
regulation since 2014 i would say i'm
very much in the details of this
sector and
i'm convinced that the organic sector
can contribute not only to
to a sustainable agriculture production
but as well
to food security but i think the
really that the challenge um the organic
sector is facing
now and is facing maybe more than um
than before is the question of
productivity i think the
organic
sector
has to question himself
how they are able
to become more or how they
can guarantee
a better outcome of harvests and more
productivity in the sector and what is
the position of the parliament on this
how or
if you could tell us more details about
how these debates were went at the
parliament yes so in the last week we
had um
on the one hand the communication
by the commission and the elements now
we talked about before and at the same
time we as parliament prepared a
communique a resolution on food security
this was not on the on my committee
level this was done on the plenary level
and there
we supported the commission
when it comes to the question what is
the priority now and in my view and in
the view of the majority
of the parliament so this communicate
this resolution
was voted with 430 colleagues in in
favor
and they
they supported the commission's opinion
that now food security is
the main priority for the european uh
union always with conditions no don't
that we do not that we do not want to
question the green deal from the fog
strategy and and so on
but now we have to guarantee a higher
production in the european
union and in my view not this will
remain in 2023 maybe longer
so mr james you you mentioned that the
the common agriculture policies are
well the agriculture policies are very
different across eu countries but how
will the new common agriculture policy
and the eu country plans contribute to
increase food security and resilience
in europe
yeah on the one hand
[Music]
we
decided to go on with the two pillars of
the common agriculture policy so that
now you have the first
um
the first pillar with the direct
payments for the farmers and on the one
hand the second pillar
which supports for farmers to be more
sustainable to do
more for climate biodiversity and animal
and animal welfare so these are the main
the main elements
which farmers have has to deal with and
on the other hand
i would say with the
more flexibilities for for the member
states to deal with the so-called echo
schemes
there is room
to adapt
to adapt
policies and maybe to change a little
bit
policies
[Music]
which we now
which we now have seen in the national
national national strategic plans yeah
so
in my view there is a need to adapt to
adopt some some elements
and
i hope that there is
that there is political willingness
in the european parliament to deal
to deal with this
question but the most important one for
farmers was always to guarantee the
support to guarantee the support for the
upcoming year so this means for the
years 2023 2027
and this is guaranteed with the new
common agriculture policy
going back to the comments of our
audience there is one from reliza
ivanova and she says the food will be so
expensive soon and we will can't afford
it
could you
we won't be able to afford it could you
answer to her maybe
do you think that we won't be able to
afford food yeah so on the one hand not
the best um to
to avoid them
high prices
for food
is to produce as much as we can now
because no we are facing food
shortages so it's clear that this will
that this will happen and this is clear
that this
has to do
there or
there is a
background that the more food we produce
the less the price
will be for for this food this is
one argument and the other one i see
there this is more
a question how the member states
would have to deal
when there are
people in their countries
which are no more able
to buy
would not say to buy food as such but to
buy enough food because
they are the poorer ones in in their
country and i think this is up to the
member states to find elements
instruments to support um
to support the
people
so what we see
now um or what we saw in the last days
and weeks in the
within the energy sector there were a
lot of
measures taken by the member states to
support
people and to guarantee their mobility
their mobility the the taxes for diesel
or for petrol and and so on they were
reduced even there were
there we saw state aid
for uh heating
the flats and and so on and the same
maybe
should be the case in a few weeks or
months
when it comes to food
so mr liens let's leave it here thank
you very very much for your time thank
you for joining us and of course thank
you to our viewers for tuning in once
again and have a good afternoon thank
you very much
you